[Applause]
this is just a game
right
[Music]
but it's not it's really not it's so
much more than that
I want to show you a story that feels
unique to our time in history it's a
story of how the organization that
controls the sport that humans love most
was hijacked
tiny country that controls the resource
that humans need most Qatar wealth from
oil and natural gas resulting in this
a World Cup held in the desert in a
country built off fossil fuels and
foreign labor with a citizen population
the size of Honolulu Hawaii
[Music]
I want to show you how this happened how
Qatar this tiny country beat out the U.S
Australia Japan and South Korea by
convincing 14 of the 22 most powerful
men in football to vote for them to
become the host of the 2022 World Cup
the winner
to organize
the 222 FIFA World Cup is Qatar
okay this is a big story and I'm excited
to dive in but before we do I need to
thank today's sponsor one of the most
unique I've ever been a part of thank
you established titles for sponsoring
today's video so this is custom in
Scotland that if you own land in
Scotland you are officially considered a
lord or lady or Laird and this company
established titles allows you to
purchase a bit of land and become a lord
which is something I've been shy to tell
you I have recently became I I may
change my YouTube channel to Lord Johnny
Harris and I expect anyone in the
comments to address me as Lord thank you
no but seriously established titles
allows you to buy a plot of land in
Scotland you buy this you get a plaque
that says you're a lord you can
literally put this as your prefix on
your credit card or your plane tickets
with every order established titles
plants a tree they work with global
Charities to focus on deforestation like
that's what's really going on here yes
this is a fun novel interesting way to
say that you're a lord or to give a gift
in fact I may gift this to my
brother-in-law for Christmas and for the
first 200 people who purchase a plot of
land using the link in my description
you will be next to my plot like we will
all have land together in Scotland right
now established titles is running a
massive Black Friday sale you get an
additional 10 off so go to the link in
my description it's established
house.com Johnny Harris clicking that
link helps support this channel use the
code Johnny Harris and you'll get an
additional 10 off it's time to dive back
in to this very deep but very important
story
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
we've been deep in this trying to make a
web trying to make a visual that will
help us understand FIFA and why this
world cup is being held where it's being
held
[Music]
I want to show it to you and I've been
really wrestling with how to boil this
down and I think there's just three
major things that we need to understand
if we want to understand how Qatar
bought the World Cup check this out
okay
there's three major things you have to
understand to make sense of this story
they are FIFA you have to understand the
World Cup and you have to understand
Qatar all right this is our list if you
understand these three things
independently you can put them together
to determine what really happened here
and how this tiny desert country ended
up with the World Cup so let's start
with FIFA
FIFA was started by seven European
nations in 1904. the original goal here
was to help organize matches for
association football which is the
football it's the thing we all know it's
the game where two teams of 11 players
try to kick a ball into a goal football
was no means invented here at this time
at this place people have been kicking a
ball around for like a million years but
it was here in Europe in the early 1900s
when the modern Authority for football
was born and born in pretty humble
beginnings but FIFA quickly grew into a
transnational quasi-political Authority
that spans the whole globe fact we have
a map for that
[Music]
so this is Fifa today it is massive it
represents 211 countries or associations
that all belong to this one giant
sporting organization it's the most
powerful easily the most powerful
sporting organization in the world and
it's got these six major regions or
confederations and it was the leaders
from these Regional confederations who
in 2010 sat on FIFA's executive
committee based here in Zurich in this
bunker-like headquarters I was actually
there just a few weeks ago actually I'm
in Zurich this is where the FIFA
headquarters the FIFA Museum are this is
where the votes happened
[Music]
we include
okay let's get back to this here we go
the 24 most powerful men in football the
ones who would go on to decide who would
be the host of the 2022 World Cup
here they are
just hanging out on our diagram
sorted by their confederations set
bladder to the President right here at
the top Swiss guy
I'm gonna cross it off I'm going to
cross it off the list FIFA we didn't go
over all of it there's obviously way
more to FIFA than what I just talked
about the corruption the scandals all of
it but for the purposes of this video
which is trying to answer the question
how did Qatar end up with the World Cup
what we need to know is what we just
talked about the executive committee the
24 most powerful men in football
I'm going to cross it off the list
next on our list the World Cup
[Music]
So eventually FIFA got big enough to
where they could put on a big
International Tournament and people
would actually come they held it in
Uruguay in 1930 13 teams participated
and they called it the World Cup it
quickly became the most prestigious
tournament in football and eventually
would become the most viewed sports
event on the planet
[Music]
beating out even the Olympics if you
consider that 1.1 billion people like a
decent chunk of the entire global
population were simultaneously watching
in 2018 when France beat Croatia in the
World Cup Final in Moscow
1.1 billion people at the same time all
watching the same thing and I mean
that's that's insane but it's also kind
of amazing like what other thing brings
that many people together it is an
amazing thing what Global football has
become and that is basically thanks to
FIFA
this was his stage
[Music]
spot has the power to inspire and unite
people
I mean you and me I'm immediately like
actually almost crying like this is this
is beautiful stuff look at this look at
this guy look at this these moments of
like
amazing like performance and then the
reaction of these crowds
but it must be noted that when you have
this much attention on one event
thirteen percent of the entire global
population watching at one time it will
quickly become less about the beauty of
this game and more about I mean you know
what I'm going to say more about money
with so much attention corporations pay
endless money to get their logos
anywhere near this stuff here or here or
here okay that's not that surprising
what blows my mind is how far
governments will go to also pay endless
money to get anywhere near the World Cup
not because they make money in return
like the corporations they always end up
losing tons of money but because there's
a power in having the entire world
focused on your country for a few weeks
together you've given the American
people an extraordinary opportunity to
welcome the world to our shores as host
of the 2022 FIFA World Cup
I mean look at this look at this we
plotted this actually we found this data
every four years as a World Cup and this
is how much each of these countries have
spent on their World Cup these are again
taxpayer money here is the government
money being invested into hosting the
World Cup throw this sucker onto a bar
chart and you get something like this
like it's getting out of hand like every
year they spend more and more and more
oh and spoiler alert wait till I show
you this graph with Qatar in the mix
Minds will be blown I can promise you
that
the point is that countries are willing
to pay more and more to get the World
Cup in their country a moment for them
to put their best foot forward on a
global stage this is what we like to
call soft power
okay I am crossing the World Cup off of
our list not because I covered every
angle of it but because for the purposes
of this story this is what matters
countries are more and more willing to
pay unlimited amounts of money to try to
get this event in their country because
a billion people are going to watch it
it makes them look good okay we're
crossing It Off
all right on to the last piece of our
puzzle Qatar a country that should be
pronounced but I'm not going to be that
pretentious guy who shows up trying to
like say it in the local pronunciation
because it makes me sound cultured and
cool I am that guy I'm trying to not be
that guy so for now I'm just gonna say
it like a Texas oilman says it Qatar
okay
thanks
thank you
I'm going to be really quick on this
history of Qatar like we're not going
into the full thing okay this is a very
juicy history that I could easily do a
whole video about I'm going to give you
the spark notes which is that Qatar for
most of its history was populated by
nomadic tribes and fishing villages
whose biggest industry was Pearl diving
which is like a pretty gnarly thing to
do like do you like tie a rock around
your ankle and go under to find clams
and then open the clams and see if
there's pearls it was like hard work the
British eventually swooped in because
the Industrial Revolution was happening
and they smelled oil over here Qatar
becomes a British protectorate until
1971 when they became an independent
country an Islamic constitutional
monarchy Run by One family Dynasty so by
the 70s the British were gone but
crucially the oil was not and because of
said oil Qatar quickly transitioned from
a poor tribal Society to a globally
connected energy Hub with unlimited
money this accelerated in the 70s when
Qatar won the fossil fuel Lottery and
discovered that they just happened to be
sitting on the largest known natural gas
field on the planet this guy
they share a bit of it with the
territorial Waters of Iran but
most of it's theirs
oh and by the way all this fossil fuel
and the revenue coming from it belongs
to this teeny country which this is a
very teeny country like we're talking
about a country that fits inside of the
soul of the boot of Italy look at this
I mean it doesn't totally fit but it's
tiny and we're talking about a few
hundred thousand qataris here this isn't
a big population and yet they're all
getting in on this unbelievable amount
of wealth
like we can't fathom how rich this teeny
little thumb shaped country is they
could not spend their money fast enough
they didn't have enough labor to build
all the stuff that they had money for so
they started to import labor from other
countries 95 of the people who live and
work here are not qataris they're expats
from other places 95 meanwhile the Teeny
population that are actually Qatari
citizens
live very good lives they're some of the
richest people on the planet most of
them work very cushy government jobs
that pay really well they live in a
welfare state where their needs are met
because there is just unlimited money
for everyone in this country okay that's
Qatar
so this is the moment where the three
pieces of our puzzle come together
because in the 90s Qatar starts to read
the tea leaves they start to realize
that the world is going to move away
from fossil fuels the one thing that
they have their gravy train is going to
come to an end in a few decades it's
time to prepare for the future said
Guitar by investing their billions and
billions hundreds of billions of extra
dollars into anything and everything
that is not fossil fuels diversify so
they start to go nuts everything from
Real Estate in Singapore and New York
City to bind the St Petersburg airport
in Russia to bind Miramax films and the
Italian luxury brand Valentino like boy
should I just make an entire video on
Qatar investment Authority because that
would be juicy in 2017 the BBC noted
that Qatar owns more land in the UK than
the queen does and as a part of this big
diversifying Strategic investment effort
Qatar focused on turning their country
into a global hub for prestigious
international events you see where I'm
going with this
lucky for them there is a shortcut to
the most prestigious event in the world
the World Cup
oh and this event happens to be run by
an organization that speaks a language
that they're very familiar with the
language of money and power and
influence
and here's where we are
[Music]
so we're back here to this web these
Gatekeepers of International Football
the people who voted on who was going to
host the 2022 World Cup
14 of these guys voted Qatar and I want
to know why Qatar a country that FIFA
itself when they were evaluating all the
bidders for the hosting decided was not
super suited for this there's all these
parameters that countries should have to
be a good host Qatar didn't really have
a lot of them in fact they had the
opposite
hot weather no widespread football
infrastructure and perhaps most
strikingly not a huge tradition of
football or even a significant local
population to spread football to in
their place they have a couple hundred
thousand people the World Cup is
supposed to bring football to new
regions and spread it throughout a
country how are they going to do that in
a hot Desert Oasis with like 300 000
people so let's do this
we're done with our list
let's move on to the next part of this
video which is
probably the part we put the most effort
into and I want you to stick with me
here because the point isn't to go into
every single detail of how some of this
corruption went down no one's going to
remember every little detail that's not
the point the point is to give you a
sampling of the mechanics of how
influence and power works not just in
FIFA but in the International System
generally how powerful people get what
they want we'll never know for certain
because this vote was secret but we know
Qatar got 14 of these guys and I think I
have a pretty good idea of how for most
of them
we're going to start with this guy
this is Muhammad binham he's one of the
executive committee members and he's
from Qatar okay we can safely assume
that he probably voted for his own
country but more importantly it was him
a big wig International football guy who
helped pull the strings on everyone else
on this web starting with this guy
[Music]
Jack Warner he's an executive committee
member from Trinidad and Tobago leaked
emails and bank records obtained by the
Sunday Times revealed that before the
vote binham deposited 450 thousand
dollars directly into Warner's account
and later even more totaling 1.6 million
dollars
just like literally like he just paid
him like that this is the simplest
version just like I will pay you money
to give to so you do what I want you to
it's just like so straightforward no
wonder a month after the vote in an
email Warner called his Qatari colleague
Ben hamam quote the only brother I have
in football
okay one guy down who else next we have
the three executive committee members
from the South American Confederation
the U.S department of justice has gotten
involved with these guys they recently
released an unsealed indictment against
all three of them alleging that these
three were quote offered and received
bribes in exchange for their votes I
mean it's pretty unsatisfying we don't
have the evidence that the doj is using
for this case but they're building a
case oh and by the way two of these guys
just died in like the past couple of
years
next up we've got these three guys from
the Africa Confederation
a year before the vote the African
Confederation was having their annual
meeting in Angola which by the way was
paid for by the Qatar bid team the
people who were like trying to convince
people to vote for the World Cup they
paid for the whole thing okay
I get it trying to like Lobby for your
team that's fine but here's where it
gets Shady while they were at this
meeting the Qatar bid team met with
these three executive committee members
and according to a former employee who
was in the room translating the qataris
offered 1.5 million dollars each to
these guys in exchange for their promise
that they would vote for Qatar
a year later this employee turned
whistleblower actually went back on her
statement saying that she actually lied
about it and that there were no bribes
kind of fishy what's your incentive to
lie but then the FBI showed up at her
front door and she admitted that she was
pressured to say that she had lied about
it and that actually the bribes happened
I don't know man we don't like I I side
with the Whistleblower you can decide
how you feel and now her life is
basically ruined she said in an
interview that quote I will always look
over my shoulder for the rest of my life
oh okay and while we're talking about
this one of those three guys that
apparently got 1.5 million dollars was
later filmed by undercover reporters
negotiating an 800 000 bribe in exchange
for his vote like Smoking Gun evidence
same thing happened to this guy the
executive committee member from the
Oceania region and they actually got
disqualified from voting so these two
guys didn't actually vote
so we're now down to 22 exco members
let's keep going
Okay so we've gone over the instances
where there was direct money given in
exchange for the promise to vote the
next phase of the story are more subtle
versions of influence less overt less
smoking gunnish like this guy from
Thailand he's the executive committee
member from Thailand
four months before the vote Thailand and
Qatar were renegotiating an energy deal
Thailand was trying to get a better
price for their natural gas something
Qatar has a lot of but for some reason
this guy a FIFA executive committee
voting member was at the meeting wait
what why is this football guy in the
room while there's these big gas
negotiations going on yes I'm being koi
we know where this is going I mean you
got to read these leaked emails they're
so juicy you've got a FIFA guy emailing
a guitar gas guy from Qatar petroleum
they're talking about the development of
their two football associations from
their different countries and then
saying that they're going to liaise with
the CEO of the gas company to follow up
about a liquid natural gas sale I mean
it's just so clear what's going on here
favorable terms of the deal in exchange
for hey dude make sure to vote for our
country
oh and who was this meeting between the
gas guy and the FIFA guy arranged by you
guessed it this guy Muhammad bin hamam
the executive committee member from
Qatar who's pulling all these strings oh
by the way just a little side note here
going through these leaked emails I
couldn't help but notice that the FIFA
guy's email was Sour Piggy at redacted
sour Piggy
sour Boogie sour Boogie's doing a lot of
corruption ladies okay
oh [ __ ] okay okay okay and then there's
a few just like sort of circumstantial
ones that give you a flavor of how this
works like this guy who sold his
family's land to Qatar a year after the
vote for 27 million pounds which was
like way over asking price and this
executive committee member whose son was
given a job at a private Qatari Hospital
shortly after the World Cup vote both of
these guys of course like everyone else
on this list denies any connection that
this was influenced but now we're at the
most significant moment in all of this
the thing that really tipped the scales
for the vote and it has to do with this
confederation the most powerful the
European Confederation specifically this
guy Michelle platini a former French
football player turned FIFA guy he was
the president of this confederation
which inevitably meant that he has sway
over these other dudes just one week
before the vote like crunch time platini
got an invitation that he couldn't
refuse a luncheon with the French
president at his Palace platini later
said that before this meeting he was
planning on voting for the U.S to host
the World Cup in 2022 but he goes to
this luncheon and who else is there no
no big deal just these two guys the most
powerful dudes in Qatar one of them the
prime minister of Qatar and the other
the current Emir of Qatar from like the
old Dynasty family it's important to
remember the context here like what's
happening this is 2010 the world has
just been rattled by a Global Financial
meltdown and the president of France
Sarkozy is stressed and he's in the room
with the leaders of Qatar who are not
nearly in the same financial trouble see
the section before about unlimited
amounts of money thanks to fossil fuels
and it's clear that these qataris want
something something that the Frenchman
in the room can deliver them a vote for
their country to host the World Cup
something they really want according to
sources close to this meeting Sarkozy
flat out told platini to vote for Qatar
why well we'll never know but it's clear
that he wanted a few things from Qatar
in this same meeting Sarkozy told the
qataris that he wanted Qatar to buy the
French football team Paris Saint German
which happens to be sarkozy's favorite
football team and at the time was in
financial ruin after this meeting a few
important things happen number one Qatar
did end up buying that football team for
60 million pounds just like Sarkozy
wanted they turned it around and soon it
became a star-studded team with merch
that's worn by the world's most popular
celebrities and then we suddenly see an
uptick in big trade deals between Qatar
and France Qatar Airways buys 50 giant
planes from Airbus the giant French
airplane maker I mean if you look at
what one of these planes cost in 2010
times it by 50 we're looking at 18
billion dollars a massive deal and in
the end platini in this room with his
President telling him to do what the
qataris want we need them right now and
it worked Michelle platini flipped his
vote from the USA to Qatar he admitted
it later that's not even speculation the
president of the executive committee
said blatter was pissed about this and
later said that this was the defining
moment for Qatar winning they have
influenced Michelle platini at that time
to vote for Qatar because remember
patini then went back to his European
Confederation with eight executive
committee members eight votes and he
almost certainly influenced others to
join him one book I read claims that he
took four votes with him but we'll never
know and then on a cold day in December
of 2010 the day of the vote came the 22
FIFA World Cup so on that fateful day in
the winter of 2010 in Zurich all the
guests arrive because it was Voting day
[Music]
I think we had an absolutely fantastic
Beast well we got a great bit so we just
got to go in there and give it
everything that we've got these 22 Men
cast their votes in multiple rounds
until a majority Victor emerged at least
11 of them voted from Qatar since round
one
and finally 14 votes were delivered to
Qatar a majority and almost double what
the USA got
[Music]
how it went down
that's how it went down like look we'll
never know exactly what happened a lot
of this stuff we know because it leaked
out and we were able to put it all
together but the fact is every one of
these men has been involved in some
corruption investigation I mean it's no
surprise that this stuff happened and
probably so much more FIFA is corrupt to
the core Qatar didn't make this happen
Qatar just saw an organization that
spoke their language the language of
unlimited money and they used that to
get what they wanted to prepare for the
future to diversify to get the world to
look at them
[Music]
so no this isn't just a game the reason
why all of this matters is because
football can be a beautiful thing no
matter what language someone speaks
whether politics or their God or
whatever they have this universal
language this game a global culture full
of screaming and cheering and crying and
pride and identity it's ridiculous yet
so beautiful so uniquely human and in a
very real way football is a mirror to
the world what's acceptable here in this
most revered sport is what's acceptable
everywhere so by using money and
influence to get the bid for the World
Cup Qatar showed us just how power Works
in our world they showed us who really
matters and who doesn't and validated an
old idea that the rules of fair play
don't really matter if you have enough
money
foreign
hey thanks for watching and for sticking
around till the end of the video this is
just the first of two videos we made on
this topic the next video publishes soon
and it's kind of the next chapter of the
story of what happens after guitar gets
hold of the World Cup and they have to
build all this infrastructure
and it's a very long intense Journey
that I go on to report that story and I
kind of tell the story of that reporting
experience so that will be out soon
um I want to tell you about a couple
ways that you can support our journalism
here we do these deep Dives they take a
lot of effort and we need support not
just from sponsors but more and more
from the community we have a community
called The Newsroom which is over on
patreon and it is a place where you can
get a an extra video every month it is a
behind the scenes Vlog of everything
that happens in uh this studio behind
the scenes
um the fun the wild the Deep Dives
um the animation the editing the the
team the whole universe that exists
behind the camera I'm just one Cog of a
very big machine that we're building
here you also get access to my scripts
to um interviews that I do with experts
that are just like the full length
interview I have influence on thumbnails
and titles and even story ideas so go
check out The Newsroom over on patreon
the link is in my description if you're
a video person or a photo person we also
have Luts and presets that we use to
color our videos and photos we developed
these over the course of a year with a
professional colorist they're very
wonderful and
um purchasing those you can use them and
they also help support us over here so
those are a couple ways that you can
support if you'd like to thank you for
watching this video And subscribe if you
haven't already I will see you very soon
in the continuation of this story
see ya